there's legends of uh your nutritional
intake uh
in the early days uh what can you say
about
a sort of as a you know
being a programmer is a kind of athlete
so what what what was uh the nutrition
that fueled i have never been that great
on i
on really paying attention to it where
i'm good enough that i i don't eat a lot
you know i've never been like a big
heavy guy but
uh it was interesting where one of the
things that i can remember being an
unhappy teenager not having enough money
and like one of the things that bothered
me about not having enough money is i
couldn't buy pizza whenever i wanted to
so i got rich and then i bought a whole
lot of pizza that was just defining like
that's what being rich felt like a lot
of the little things like i could buy
all the pizza and comic books and video
games that uh that i wanted to and it
really didn't take that much but uh the
pizza was one of those things and it's
absolutely true that for a long time it
did software i had a pizza delivered
every single day you know the delivery
guy knew me my name and i didn't find
out until years later that apparently i
was such a good customer that they just
never raised the price on me and i was
using this six-year-old price for the
pizzas that they were still kind of
sending my way every day so you were
doing um eating once a day
or were you it would be spread out you
know you have a few pieces of pizza you
have some more later on and i'd maybe
have something at home i it was one of
the nice things that facebook meta is
they do they feed you quite well you get
a different i guess now it's doordash
sorts of things delivered but
they take care of making sure that
everybody does get well-fed i probably
had better food than those
six years that i was working in the meta
office there than i used to before
but i've it's worked out okay for me my
health has always been good i get a
pretty good amount of exercise
and
i don't eat to excess and i avoid a lot
of other kind of not so good for you
things so i'm still doing quite well at
my age did you have a
a kind of
i don't know spiritual experience with
food or coffee or any of that kind of
stuff i mean
you know the programming experience you
know with music and or
or like i listen to brown noise on a
program or like creating an environment
and the things you take into your body
just everything you construct can become
a kind of ritual that empowers the whole
process of the program did you have that
relationship with pizza or um it would
really be with diet coke there still is
that sense of you know drop the can down
crack open the can of diet coke all
right now i mean business we're getting
to work here
but still to this day yeah it's diet
coke still part yeah probably
eight or nine a day
nice
you